there are many videos on khan academy
where we talk about factoring
polynomials but what we're going to do
in this video is do a few more examples
of factoring higher degree polynomials
so let's start with a little bit of a
warm up let's say that we wanted to
factor six x squared
plus nine x
times x squared
minus four x plus four pause this video
and see if you can factor this into the
product of even more expressions
all right now let's do this together and
the way that this might be a little bit
different than what you've seen before
is this is already partially factored
this polynomial this higher degree
polynomial is already expressed as the
product of two quadratic expressions but
as you might be able to tell we can
factor this further
for example 6x squared plus 9x both 6x
squared and 9x are divisible by 3x
so let's factor out a 3x here so this is
the same thing as 3x times 3x times what
is 6x squared
well 3 times 2 is 6 and x times
x is x squared and then 3x times what is
9x well 3x times 3
is 9x and you can verify that if we were
to distribute this 3x you would get 6x
squared plus 9x
and then what about this second
expression right over here can we factor
this
well you might recognize this as a
perfect square some of you might have
said hey i need to come up with two
numbers whose product is 4 and whose sum
is negative 4 and you might say hey
that's negative 2 and negative 2.
and so this would be
x
minus 2 we could write x minus 2 squared
or we could write it as x minus 2 times
x minus 2. if what i just did is
unfamiliar i encourage you to go back
and watch videos on factoring perfect
square quadratics and things like that
but there you have it i think we have
factored this as far as we could go
so now let's do a slightly trickier
higher degree polynomial
so let's say we wanted to factor
x to the third
minus 4 x squared plus 6 x
minus 24
and i just like always pause this video
and see if you can have a go at it and
i'll give you a little bit of a hint you
can factor in this case by grouping
and in some ways it's a little bit
easier than what we've done in the past
historically when we've learned
factoring by grouping we've looked at a
quadratic and then we looked at the
middle term the x term of the quadratic
and we broke it up so that we had four
terms here we already have four terms
and see if you could have a go at that
all right now let's do it together
so you can't always factor a third
degree polynomial by grouping but
sometimes you can so it's good to look
for it so when we see it written like
this we say okay x to the third minus 4x
squared is there a common factor here
well yeah both x to the third and
negative four x squared are divisible by
x squared so what happens if we factor
out an x squared so that's x squared
times
x
minus four and what about these second
two terms is there a common factor
between 6x and negative 24
yeah they're both divisible by
6. so let's factor out a 6 here so plus
6
times
x minus 4.
and now you are probably seeing the home
stretch
where you have something times x minus 4
and then something else times x minus 4.
and so you can sometimes i like to say
undistribute the x minus 4 or factor out
the x minus 4. and so this is going to
be x minus 4
times
x squared
x squared
plus
6.
and
we are done